so let's take a closer look at the
situation around europe
in the uk infections are still rising
with 150 new cases for every 100
000 people they're up to in portugal but
still
lower at 109 elsewhere cases are
declining or level
moving on to the travel green list are
the balearic islands with a rate of just
24
and malta which has just four cases for
every 100 000 people
so on that measure there would be a
higher risk of us exporting the virus
than actually bringing it back from
holiday which is why angela merkel the
german chancellor
wants british visitors to the eu to
quarantine
but that could flip the other way around
by the end of the summer
23 of the 30 countries in the european
economic area have now reported cases of
the more infectious
delta variant and it's spreading eu
health officials predict that by
early august it will account for 70
percent of cases
and by the end of the month it'll be 90
percent
it warns that the continent could suffer
a coveted wave at least
as bad as last autumn unless
vaccinations sharply increase and this
is their concern in the uk more than 60
percent of adults
have the protection of two doses but
apart from malta
which is ahead at 67 percent in other
european countries
barely a third of adults have been
double-dosed giving the virus a better
chance of spreading
now it sounds gloomy but don't give up
hope of a getaway
the government says it hopes to give
people who've been double vaccinated
extra travel freedoms by the summer
that's because they're between 60 and 79
less likely to get infected so the
travel rules
change once again and they'll surely do
so
even more as the pandemic waxes and
wanes